[Music]
president donald trump has tested
positive for covid19
[Music]
trump is 74 years old and
not to mention overweight advanced age
and
obesity are two factors that put someone
at high risk of death from covet 19.
so what would happen if the president
died just before the u.s election
how would this affect the election
who would the new presidential candidate
be
and how would this new candidate be
chosen
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the u.s president dies before the
election
if something like this did happen it
would be for the first time
the closest anything like this has
happened before occurred in 1912
when a vice presidential candidate died
just days before the election
but what if instead of a vice president
passing away
it was the president just weeks before
the election
normally if a president dies while in
office
the vice president would take over so
vice president mike pence would
take over the role of commander-in-chief
along with
any other presidential duties but
that doesn't necessarily mean that pence
would be the republican party's
presidential nominee in the upcoming
election
although he would be the most likely
choice to be the new presidential
nominee
it isn't guaranteed if the president
dies
the republican national committee would
have to vote again
to decide who their new nominee would be
and sure
let's assume it is going to be pence if
this had happened
six months ago the republican party
would have been able to put
pence's name on the ballot but since
it's
so close to the election there would be
no way to change
what's on the voting ballot each state
has
a deadline to put new candidates on the
ballot and those deadlines have passed
and there's another small detail
early voters have already cast their
ballot
so this is where things could get
complicated
people could still be voting for trump
on the ballot but
technically it could be for the
republican party's new candidate
mike pence and although joe biden tested
negative
shortly after the first presidential
debate what if he contracted covet 19
and then died
well it would be largely the same
process
the democratic party would need to
nominate a new candidate
kamala harris would be one of the top
choices but who's to say bernie sanders
wouldn't get nominated
this process would once again be messy
complicated
and at times pretty scary americans
voting for joe biden
on the ballot might not know exactly who
they'd be voting for if something like
this happened
now what if trump were to win the
election on november 3rd
and then died shortly thereafter
well since this has never happened
before
there's definitely some uncertainty in
this scenario
after november 3rd when all the votes
have been cast
the electoral college of each state
would meet
to vote for a new president based on how
many votes each candidate received
if this happened most state electors
would just vote for the vice
presidential nominee for president
but other states specifically state that
electors must vote for the name on the
ballot
and in this case that would be trump
this could open the door for months of
legal actions and courtroom battles
but regardless the 20th amendment of the
united states constitution
states that if a president-elect dies
the vice president-elect would become
president
but there's still lots of uncertainty
and
complications about how this could play
out
and could the president dying or getting
sick
delay the election well the president
doesn't have the power to do that and
although
congress could delay it it's very
unlikely
it would happen what's most likely to
happen if the president dies this close
to the election
is that mike pence would be the new
republican nominee
and if the republican party wins then
mike pence would become the president of
the united states
but what if pence were to get sick and
die morbid
i know but it is a question worth asking
if that were to happen then the speaker
of the house nancy pelosi would become
president
and if she were to die it would go to
the president
pro tempore of the senate and if that
person dies
then it would go down to a list of
secretaries of the cabinet
and hopefully all the dying stops at
that point
but since something like this has never
happened before
the results could be complicated and we
don't know exactly what would happen
[Music]
2020 throws us another curveball
hey do you want to know some tips on how
to survive this crazy year
well check out our new show how to
[Music]
survive